PRESIDENT IS, TO DISEMBARK AND
TALK TO THE FOLKS THERE IN
WINSTON-SALEM.
THIS COMES THAT’S ABOUT AROUND
STATES ARE SHOWING TIGHTENING,
ONE OF THEM BEING FLORIDA COME
UP THE BIGGEST BATTLEGROUND OF
ALL.
A NEW POLL FROM NBC MARIST HAS
VERY TIGHT, ESSENTIALLY TIED.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE INTERNALS,
YOU COMPARE THE 2016 EXIT POLLS
WITH HILLARY CLINTON AND
DONALD TRUMP, AND THAT 62-35.
BUT IN THIS WHOLE JOE BIDEN AT
46 AND DONALD TRUMP AT 60% AND
THAT IS TRACKING SOME LATINO
NUMBERS AS WELL AS ONE ELEMENT.
WE ALWAYS LOOK AT THOSE POLLS AS
SNAPSHOTS IN TIME BUT IT’S
INTERESTING TO LOOK AT THEM.
BILL BENNETT, FORMER EDUCATION
SECRETARY AND HOST OF THE BILL
BENNETT SHOW PODCAST.
AMY STODDARD AND MICHAEL
CONTINUITY, EDITOR OF
"THE WASHINGTON FREE BEACON."
LET ME START WITH YOU.
IT IS INTERESTING TO SEE THAT
SHIFT IN JUST A FEW WEEKS.
>> I DID ALWAYS THINK THAT THEY
WERE GOING TO COME HOME.
THE CAMPAIGN EXPECTED THE
INTEREST AND ENGAGEMENT ON HIS
SIDE WILL BE HEIGHTENED AROUND
THAT TIME AND THEY WOULD HAVE TO
BE PREPARED.
SO I THINK IF YOU ARE THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN YOU JUST HAVE TO
CONTEST EVERYWHERE YOU CAN WITH
ALL THE FOREST AND ABILITY THAT
YOU CAN.
IF YOU ARE THE BIDEN CAMPAIGN, I
THINK THAT’S WHAT YOU’VE BEEN
SAYING LIKE THEY’VE BEEN SAYING
FOR MONTHS THEY WERE GOING TO DO
WHICH IS DEFEND MINNESOTA,
NEW HAMPSHIRE, AND NEVADA AND
NOT BE SEDUCED BY TEXAS AND
GEORGIA.
THEY ARE MORE CAUTIOUS THAN
PEOPLE GETTING CREDIT FOR, AND
IT’S STILL GOING TO BE A VERY
VOLATILE TIME BETWEEN NOW AND
ELECTION DAY.
>> WE HAVE THIS WHAT IF SCENARIO
ON THE MAP.
IF THIS IS TRUE, AND THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN IS PICKING UP LATINO
VOTERS IN PLACES LIKE FLORIDA
AND NORTH CAROLINA, IF THEY ARE
MOVING THE NEEDLE IN THE BLACK
VOTE BY ONE, TWO, THREE POINTS,
AND SOME OF THE STATES THAT
REALLY COULD TURN THE TIDE.
>> I UNDERSTAND IF WE GO FROM
EIGHT POINTS, SOMETIMES 11 OR 12
AND THAT MOVEMENT AMONG HISPANIC
VOTERS AND LATINO COMMUNITIES IS
DRAMATIC.
IT’S TIGHTENING BUT IT’S ALSO
HEATING UP AND IT’S GOT KIND OF
INTENSITY NOW THAT SOMETIMES
IT’S JUST RESERVED FOR OCTOBER.
THE OTHER THING IS FROM SPORTS,
WE LEARN FROM WASHINGTON ON
OFFENSE OR DEFENSE.
TRUMP IS ON OFFENSE AND
JOE BIDEN IS ON DEFENSE.
REMEMBER THIS GUY IS LIKE 72 AND
THIS IS A HERCULEAN SCHEDULE
THAT DRUM AT DONALD TRUMP KEEPS
WITH NO SIGN OF SLOWING DOWN.
YOU ARE ON OFF OFFENSE AND
DEFENSE AND I THINK THAT’S A
VERY GOOD THING.
THE OTHER THING IS WE ARE SO
ROYAL IS A COUNTRY SPLITS
DIVISIONS, I THINK THE FIRMNESS
OF TRUMP, AND HIS STRENGTHS AND
WHATEVER PEOPLE MAY THINK OF HIS
OCCASIONAL SOLICITORS MAY BRING
MODERATES BACK TO DONALD TRUMP.
THEY WANT SOME CERTAIN HAVE BEEN
HERE IF HE CURSES FROM TIME TO
TIME.
AND YOU SEE THE FORMER
VICE PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN TAKING
THE DAY OFF TO CAMPAIGN TRAIL,
NO EVENTS FOR BIDEN OR HARRIS
TODAY AND WE WERE KIND OF
SURPRISED THAT WE SAW THAT THE
LID FOR THE PRESS WAS ON BY
MIDDAY.
>> THERE ARE TWO VERY DIFFERENT
CANDIDATES THAT REMODELING TWO
DIFFERENT TYPES OF CAMPAIGNS,
THE PRESIDENT TRYING TO
DEMONSTRATE THAT AMERICA IS BACK
AND THAT WE ARE PUTTING THE
PANDEMIC BEHIND US.
JOE BIDEN IS STILL VERY MUCH
BELIEVING THAT WE NEED TO TAKE
STEPS TO CONTAIN AND SUPPRESS
THE VIRUS.
A FEW THINGS ABOUT THE
TIGHTENING THOUGH, I THINK IT’S
VERY IMPORTANT WHEN YOU CONSIDER
THAT THIS ELECTION IN 2016 WAS
DECIDED BY FEWER THAN 100,000
VOTES.
IT CAN BE A VERY NARROW MARGIN
TO HAVE TWO SIDES THE RESULTS IN
THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE, AS
SOMETHING VERY SIMILAR HAPPENING
NOT JUST IN THREE STATES BUT MAY
BE IN SIX.
THAT COULD LEAD TO A VERY
PROLONGED POSTELECTION THE OTHER
THING I WOULD NOTE IS THAT THE
HISPANIC VOTE, IF TRUMP SHOULD
WIN THE ELECTION OF THE
DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL CONVENTION
WILL BE SEEN AS A MISSED
OPPORTUNITY BY THE BIDEN-HARRIS
TICKET.
IT HAD VERY LITTLE TO SAY TO
LATINO VOTERS AND THERE’S THIS
MISCONCEPTION THAT LATINO VOTERS
VOTE SOLELY IMMIGRATION.
THAT’S NOT THE CASE, WHAT’S MORE
IMPORTANT TO THEM IS ECONOMY AND
TRUMPS ECONOMIC MISSION IS MORE
POWERFUL THAN JOE BIDEN’S.
>> Bret: WHILE ENDING FLORIDA
THEY ARE PLAYING THE DON’T VOTE
SOCIALIST AND THAT ADDS TO THE
CUBAN-AMERICAN AND PUERTO RICAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITIES.
THE MONEY GAME, JOE BIDEN
RAISING A LOT OF MONEY IN RECENT
WEEKS.
TOTAL RAISE 328 MILLION TOTAL
SPENT 229 MILLION, AND YOU TAKE
A LOOK AT THE CASH ON HAND
THERE, ROUGHLY ABOUT
$100 MILLION.
THE PRESIDENT, A BIG RAISE,
4-14, AND A HUGE SPEND.
CASH ON HAND IS A LITTLE BIT
MORE.
A PRESIDENT GOING SO FAR AS TO
SAYING HE WOULD PUT HIS OWN
MONEY IN THIS RACE, UP TO
WHATEVER HE NEEDS TO SPEND.
>> THAT’S ACTUALLY SEE IF WE
EVER CAME UP.
THIS IS A TROUBLING STORY FOR
THEM BECAUSE YOU AND EVERYONE IN
THIS PANEL, I’VE EXPRESSED
CONCERNS IN THE SUMMER MONTHS
ABOUT THE SPENDING AND THE
DISORGANIZATION, THE DRIFTING
THAT HAS GONE ON AND SPENT
ALMOST A BILLION DOLLARS TO NOT
EVEN HAVE A MESSAGE, IT HAS BEEN
A SOURCE OF A LOT OF TENSION ON
THE REPUBLICAN SIDE AND A LOT OF
CONCERN, AND NOT THE
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN.
SO HE IS ON A LOT OF
BATTLEGROUNDS RIGHT NOW.
>> Bret: DO YOU KNOW HOW MUCH
MITCH McCONNELL HAS RAISED?
IT’S A STAGGERING NUMBER, TOO,
BUT WE ARE GOING TO GET THAT.
>> THEY HAVE A LOT OF MONEY TO
SPEND AND THEY HAVE A LOT OF
EXPENSE ON THE SENATE REPUBLICAN
SIDE.
THEY HAVE MANY, MANY RACES WHERE
THE CAN MIGHT WIN BUT THEY HAVE
TO PLAY DEFENSE AND DO A LOT OF
SPENDING SO THEY NEED A LOT OF
MONEY.
AND IT’S BEEN VERY FRUSTRATING
IN THE PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN.
THEY’VE BEEN MANEUVERING ALL
THIS MONEY FOR YEARS AND THEIR
MAJORITIES NOW.
BUT I WANT TO QUICKLY SAY, SO
TRUMP IS DOWN A BATTLEGROUND
STATES FOR TV ADS, AND WE WILL
SEE LATER ON HOW EFFECTIVE THE
TV ADS ARE.
TRUMP IS UP ON YOUTUBE AND
BASEBALL FOR MANY, MANY YEARS
AND RUNNING A GENERAL ELECTION
CAMPAIGN ON SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS ALL ALONG, LONG BEFORE
THERE WAS A DEMOCRATIC NOMINEE.